the definition of neediness this is
markk Manson neediness occurs when you
place a higher priority on what others
think of you than what you think of
yourself anytime you alter your words or
behavior to fit someone else's needs
rather than your own anytime you lie
about your interests Hobbies or
background anytime you pursue a goal to
impress others rather than fulfill
yourself that is needy whereas most
people focus on what behavior is
attractive or unattractive what
determines neediness and therefore
attractiveness is the why behind your
behavior you can say the coolest thing
or do what everyone else does but if you
do it for the wrong reason it will come
off as needy and desperate and turn
people off imagine a world in which
you're unanimously adored by millions
but you hate yourself are you happy
probably not now imagine a world in
which you're disliked by everybody but
you love yourself not optimal but I
would propose that selflove you would
ultimately be happier the reason we want
validation from others is to give us a
good enough reason to validate ourselves
and if you compromise yourself in order
to gain favor with other people you'll
know